there is one world leader who is at NATO
right now who is basically calling for
peace he's saying enough of funding this
work and everybody calm down let's
respect borders etc etc uh that's the
guy that everyone in the west seems to
call a fascist these days although he
was voted democratically and is
extremely popular within his own country
I'm talking about Victor Orban of
Hungary and here he is calling for peace
as it's real news
foreign
[Music]
is he's one of the few voices in the
world on the international stage who's
just saying how about we just don't
endlessly fund this why is it that all
these Western nations want to endlessly
fund
Ukraine fighting Russia whether they
think they're fighting back whether they
think it's partially Justified fully
Justified or whatever and as I often say
at the end of the day we can arm this
guy with all of the Munitions we want we
can give them all of the f-15s we can
give them the cluster bombs and the
whole freaking thing the mother of all
Bombs all of the stuff and at the end of
the day he still has nukes so the idea
that we're going to defeat this guy
militarily that one day we're all going
to wake up and they're going to be like
it happened we defeated Russia
militarily we've taken over and by the
way then what happens post Putin
probably gets worse but it's just a
crazy notion so there's one guy who's
doing it I happen to meet that one guy
this is at the prime minister's Palace
in Hungary that's right on the Danube
River over there and we chatted for
about 10 minutes you guys know this is
during our trip about two months ago and
it was really interesting I this was you
know just the two of us chatting for
about 10 minutes or so and all he said
to me repeatedly repeatedly
was I love my country I want to protect
my country I don't think we have to have
these adventurous Wars all over the
place I want to protect my borders and
the people of my country he just
repeated that over and over he had a big
smile on his face
that's it that's it and I think that we
should be thinking a little bit more
like that within our own borders I know
that puts me outside of the mainstream
[Music]
oh